hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 basics video in this video
we're going to be covering the basics of
writing to a file
it should be noted that there are two
methods for saving data to a file and
those are writing and appending
writing to a file
will write that bit of data whatever it
is
solely to that file so that means if
there is anything there before it's
going to be gone if you use write if you
use append then you will basically add
to whatever is previously there so i'm
going to be showing both methods but
first in this video we're going to be
covering the right
so first we need something that we're
actually going to write and so for that
we're going to say text and text is
going to equal to sample
text
to
save and then we're going to have
backslash n for a
new line
and then after that we're going to have
a new line
good enough
now um
what we want to do
is
specify the save file and when you do
that you specify basically what you're
doing is your save file
equals
open so you're actually opening the file
and
in here in open open is a function and
we have parameters to fill and the first
parameter is what are we opening so
we're actually opening examplefile.txt
if it doesn't exist already
it will be created
and
then the next parameter is our intention
do we want to open it to read write or
append in our case we want to write and
that's denoted with a w
and that's all that we need so what
we're doing here is we're basically
notifying python of our intentions we're
going to open this file and our
intention is to write to it so as soon
as this is called that file is opened
and if anything was there before it's
not there anymore it's basically opened
and cleared uh with write anyways
now we want to do is actually write to
the file so that's going to be save file
dot right and what do we want to write
to this file we want to write text
after that
the next thing that we want to do
is save file dot close it's really
important to remember to close it
otherwise
it will hang open for a while and it
could cause problems with your script
but otherwise it's just going to be a
big nuisance because you won't be able
to really
further save any data basically so
either you or your script is going to
start having some trouble
so yeah so you always want to close
so now we can do is we can save and run
that
and when it's all done we can open up
where we've been coding here
and if we open that file
here
here's our file sample text to save new
line there's our file so everything is
done it'll be the file will be in the
same directory as your script since we
didn't specify any sort of file path to
it
you can also specify a file path
and you can do things like this
and that will go like two directories in
front of your
scripts file path or you can specify the
entire file path like c colon slash and
do it that way so anyways um
that's going to include writing to a
file in the next video what we're going
to be doing is appending to a file so
stay tuned for that as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions until next time